تعاني هذه الطفله ذات العشرين شهرا مرض
الملاريا فادخلت الى قسم الطوارئ الاطفال
في مستشفى ماموبي العام بالعاصمه اكرا
تكثف غانا جهودها لمكافحه المرض الذي
ينقله البعوض ويقتل طفلا كل دقيقه وفي
خطوه هي الاولى من نوعها في العالم ستكون
اول بلد افريقي
يستخدم لقاحا جديدا ضد الملاريا من جامعه
اقصد البريطانيه قد ينهي خطر هذا المرض
القاتل
الطريقه التي يعمل بها هذا اللقاح هي اننا
اخذنا مكونا واحدا فقط من طفيل الملاريا
المسؤول عن وضع الطفيلي الذي يلقح بواسطه
لدغه البعوض
منذ عام 2019 تلقى نحو 4000 طفل في ست دول
افريقيه 12 الف جرعه من لقاح الملاريا
المعروف باسم ارتوينت1 حسب ما قال باحثون
في جامعه اقسفلت حتى الان اظهرت تجارب
المرحله الطبيه الثانيه والثالثه معدله
فعاليه بنسبه خمسه وسبعين في المئه
فعاليه اللقاح في السنه الاولى 75% لكن
وكما تعلمون فان تقليل عدد الحالات وخاصه
الوفيات بنسبه 75% سيكون امرا بالغ
الاهميه
تدرس منظمه الصحه العالميه ما اذا كانت
ستوافق على اللقاح لكنها اعلنت في يناير
انها ستوسع التجارب الطبيه للقاح الى مزيد
من البلدان في جميع انحاء افريقيا
وعاقت دوره الحياه المعقده للطفيلي المسبب
للملاريا جهودا ابتكاري لقاحات لمده طويله
حث الناس على الاستمرار في استخدام
الناموسيات واتخاذ الاحتياطات الاخرى لمنع
لدغات البعوض
بالنسبه الى مرض ينقله البعوض ويهودي
بحياه اكثر من 600 الف شخص سنويا
معظمهم اطفال في افريقيا فان اللقاح يعد
خطوه مهمه الى الامام